realmente es una seguridad sin
precedentes la que se ha desplegado en
la capital de eeuu está todo el centro
de la ciudad absolutamente cerrado
desocupado hay personas que viven allí
que tienen que salir y pasar por unas
barreras de seguridad hay un ambiente de
muchísima tensión generalmente en
washington la transmisión de mando y
estado en varias es un momento de
ilusión es un momento de expectativa
donde hay una gran cantidad de pompa y
circunstancias de estos desfiles que son
tan americanos esta vez va a ser muy
diferente hay un ambiente mucho más
sobrio de preocupación lo que se ha
mostrado realmente han sido las las
tropas de la guardia nacional acostada
en el capitolio protegiendo este lugar
que es un símbolo de democracia es un la
casa del vicepresidente le han
construido una reja enorme de varios
kilómetros alrededor lo que se ve es una
ciudad preparada para lo peor y es algo
que en eeuu es poco usual y que genera
pues una cierta preocupación en medio de
la ilusión que se produce en el momento
de la toma de posesión de joe biden